Corns fucking terrible for you.
Terrible.
Absolutely terrible.
And,
and literally you can read that sign and all these people be like,
oh,
that's so beautiful.
Like all those corn stalks and then it'd be food for us forever.
And why cook when you cannot the percentage of diners or dinners rather eaten at
home that were actually made at home in the u s it is so weird to having you
here.
Not Jamie's the shit,
but this is just dinner.
So right,
so this is how many people are cooking,
but really that's the only meal.
A lower and lower.
So it's below,
it's somewhere in the 60% range.
So the percentage of it dinners eaten at home that were actually made at home in
the u s somewhere around 60% so in that 60% you got to think there's the mom or
the dad that's cooking and then the kids that are eating the food,
so they're not cooking shit.
So it's probably way lower than that in terms of the actual human beings that
are eating cooked food that they cook themselves.
So how can you,
how can it,
how can you stand on any sort of laurels at all without at least asking some
questions?
Yeah,
I mean,
people that their answers are,
they feel better if they think that they're doing no harm.
And the way to do no harm is to eat vegan.
So this is the ideology behind it.
And I understand it.
I get it.
I appreciate it.
But the fucking anger at people who don't follow that path is where it gets real
squirrely.
And it's a small number of people,
and I've talked about this in my act,
that the problem with vegans is the problem with people,
it's not veganism.
It's people.
If you get a room that has a hundred people in it,
the odds of one of those people being a fucking idiot is 100% it's almost a
hundred percent that one of them is a fucking idiot.
Yeah.
So if you get 300 million people,
you have 3 million fucking idiots.
And some of those folks are vegans.
And that's the problem with veganism.
It's not,
it's not veganism itself.
It's,
there's a certain percentage of human beings that they don't have to do anything
to become vegans.
Right.
They just joined this group.
It's not like you have it.
Well we're,
we're thinking about louring you in to the Vegan culture,
but we want to know what your philosophy is.
Are you a hateful person?
Are you a person is looking to be a Vegan.
So you could just talk shit about other people.
Are you looking to be angry?
You're looking to be in a group or a gang,
a plant based gang,
and put the word Vegan in front of your name and just start talking shit.
Cause that's a lot of the people.
Yeah.
And so people read all these angry,
hateful things that these people,
right.
And they go,
oh well this is vegans.
But it's not,
it's not the most vegans are not like that at all people.
Most people are not like that at all.
But there's a certain percentage of them and they claim veganism and they
usually put that name,
the word Vegan in their fucking screen name.
That's how you can spot those assholes.
Yeah.
Proud.
Yeah,
they're into it.
They're in a plant based gang.
Yeah.
That's really what happens.
And so what it is,
is not necessarily even a problem of diet.
It's a problem of human nature,
is that people love to stand on the moral high ground that will love to point
down to all the other people,
whether it's a religious issue,
like you're not eating Halau or you're not eating kosher,
or are you a,
you're eating meat on Good Friday.
Whenever the fuck it is,
they just decide that they have this moral high ground that you don't have,
so fuck you.
I'm doing it right.
And it really comes from our own questions of her own existence and this
messiness that we're all inherently aware of that life eats life big time,
big time.
There was a guy that I did a podcast without a Maine and he was,
uh,
he was for sure a vegetarian.
He might've been a Vegan,
but then he started and he's a forge or big time.
It's actually pretty remarkable what he does.
But I think 99% of his food he finds in the forest year round,
he's just into it.
Big Time process.
All of this food from wild apples to acorns to Tovar.
It's,
um,
what's his name?
Um,
Daniel vitality?
Yeah.
Oh,
Daniel Vitale's.
Okay.
Yeah.
Have you heard of him as well?
Yup.
So,
um,
so I did a podcast on him and he,
and he told me that,
um,
and he'd eat insects.
He didn't want it.
He has completely against hunting.
He didn't want to kill anything.
He's like,
that's why he's eating insects.
And he's like,
and I would get a little bit of hate mail.
Um,
when I started eating a Damsel,
flies and dragonflies,
like I'd get a little bit of hate mail.
And then,
and then a friend of his was like,
Hey,
you know,
we should,
let's go gig some frogs.
Let's go get some frogs,
you know?
And he's like,
yeah,
I dunno.
Okay,
so I'll do it.
So when he started catching frogs,
it's like,
man,
like there's a lot of meat on one of these frogs.
Like it's,
it's,
it's like 20 dragonflies,
you know.
And,
and he got,
he got a little bit more flack for it.
And then it's a buddy of his wanting to take him fishing and they caught a trout
and he's like,
oh my God,
this is like three frogs.
Like this is three frog.
And so what he's equating it to is how much work he has to go through to get
this protein or to get this,
you know,
to get this plant like you find one apple that's 15 acorns,
you know.
And so like,
he's equating this to work.
And so he get just kept moving up the food chain.
And um,
and he's like,
and then one year he killed a Turkey and he told me,
it's like I killed a snowshoe hare and he's like,
I was blown away at how much meat was on a snowshoe hares.
He's like,
that was,
you know,
three meals for him and his girlfriend try a moose.
Yeah.
And so he just kept moving up.
He killed a Turkey.
Then this last year he killed a black bear.
But he's like every stage that he's moved up,
his hate mail is went up exponentially,
but significantly.
And so it's just,
people equate all these things to,
you know,
they really,
we relate more to mammals,
obviously we're mammals,
you know,
and then you bring in something like a bear that has anthropomorphic,
mannerisms,
right?
You,
you watch a black bear for a half a day and you're like,
you see your dad,
you're like,
oh,
I just sat on his ass for four hours sometimes in the [inaudible] on his
toenails.
Yeah.
He's like,
itch does ear farted pooped over there next to the girl?
And then,
you know,
and you're like,
oh my God,
it's my dad wanting my dad.
You know?
And,
and so,
you know,
there's things like that,
but,
um,
that's where this,
I think that's where this really cool engagement comes from with hunters is,
and there's a lot of hunters,
like I talked to a lot of hundreds and I don't want to be negative,
I'm trying not to be negative,
but I talked to a lot of hundreds that have no,
I have nothing in common with them.
Absolutely nothing.
Like Johann I hunt.
I don't even think we have that uncommon because I see how Johan and this had
nothing to do with how,
like what we were just saying about vegans,
that the problem is just being a human being.
That's the amount of people that choose to hunt that or they're not well
informed and they're fucking idiots.
Yup.
And so that's,
that's the stuff is like,
same with the vegans,
you know,
there's,
I'm sure there's Vegan set sit at home and just grab their face and go,
I can't believe somebody just said that.
I can't believe they sent a death threat.
Yeah.
We're Vegan for God's best friends is a Vegan.
And,
and I know it's hilarious.
Comedian,
he's a Vegan.
I know some vegans too.
And I actually know some vegetarians that,
um,
you know,
it was an education for me,
but I had some vegetarians hit me up for meat,
you know,
and I was like,
uh,
oh,
you're vegetarian.
And they're like,
well,
yeah,
we're not going to eat this meat,
but we'd love to have some fish or deer meat from you.
I was like,
oh,
okay.
Now I'm starting to,
this was a while ago,
but I'm like,
okay,
now I'm starting to get it here.
Like people have ethical concerns about where their meat comes from.
Yeah.
My friend Jake Shields,
he's a guy who fought in the UFC and he's a worldclass Jujitsu black belt.
He's been a vegetarian.
It's whole life.
But he said he would eat meat that was hunted.
Yeah.
It was like,
cause that's,
you know,
there's no ethical,
it adds up in his head for him.
Right.
Like answers his questions and so ugly.
But that's exactly it.
I've had some awesome conversations with,
with people that were not hunters that,
um,
asked great questions.
You know,
way better than conversations I've had with guys that call themselves hunters at
times.
Some.
Yeah.
I mean,
this again,
it's the problem with human beings,
right?
It's,
there's,
there's certain people that just aren't thinking that much.
And then there's certain,
there's certain parts of the hunting culture that are really a boring there.
There,
there's,
there's people that think it's funny or fun to shoot as many animals as they can
and they don't,
they don't have any consideration to the,
that this life has been taken so that your life can be nurtured or get nutrition
from this animal.
And they're not thinking of it in terms of this cycle of life.
They're just thinking of in terms of,
you know,
it's,
it's like the worst aspects that you get,
like in a movie about hunting.